[музика]
праведника його навина застала на
побачення 24 лютого упа these на маршруті
левиця парижі я
плакала
він ще не повідомляла поверху не теж
обстріли d-pro петровська я не повірю
де почав димитися в facebook але в інший
і виявилося по всій
приїхали ми на заході ща із записуванням
і нам сказав шо шляхи евакуації адже
початку провини укрзалізниця вокуєва але вже
при блешні трейси мільйона людей з
первинних подібних і ПІФ даних регіонів
до захисні україни укрем ва жив його
інфраструктурні ролі праведні та
вікторія вірити в терапевтичну з
їх чек вже якщо сів у поїзд вже
трошки заспокоюється, тобто у нього
вже якась надія
він уже кудись їде тобто вже все
навіть там із проводжаємо хтось зі сльозами
там не все добре все я вже у поїзді то
їсти все буде добре
зинка пройти і праведний ти 10 років
хоч і звучний маршрут константинівка
київ топар вікторія їздити на
евакуаційних шляхах видами
донецької області
жінка на булатому ж два місяці польші
міся двини брада його quote ногу за тегом
прожила на робочому місці
топар гидко клімат богу прийняті душ
і попрад і промови за париже і хоча розумом
і завищуйте нами та комфорт нижчими ви
приїхали зараз у нас прибирання ось але
їсти нам слава богу там щось
приносять волонтери ну буває що ми
купуємо ну готуємо буває і тут
поїзді коли пічки топилися а ми смажили
яєчні крапки та й котлети смажимо
готували суп і картоплю та всю цю
матовим тут багато гармати за словами
та вікторії бату пасажири евакуаційних
шляхів їхньої пари бувають у стрибні чином уста
не так уже праведниця перевозила людей з
інвалідністю та сотні дітей бригада
втраченому а гаїті всім дуб омах ти як
може їх ви в
спарті та
сили
молодо мама у неї були двійня то їм було
по вісім днів
такі ось
ось це ось рахунок собою більше
запам'яталася ось такі маленькі оленьки
такі маленькі лялечки 2 взагалі ну от
ми їх вони як мало дня було та ми їх
годували
ну те що у нас було б їм ділилися на і
найстрашнішим моментом для урядів
обстріл потіха & cavid мають рацію все
дистанції вище на 10 кл in peace нижчі
за її поїзд дуже страшно був момент
коли
наш сусідній склад
скажімо так
потрапив під обстріл
ми поїхали за 10 хвилин раніше, а він їхав
ззаду та
потрапив під обстріл і в нас тоді
провідниця нашим загинула
ну з нашого депутата
тоді було страшно цієї ночі ми
пережити заданим та укрзалізниця за два
місите провини 109 залізничне в заглянув і
та ще 127 атр і малі по рани дня
російський весь регулярно обстріляю
однакові інфраструктуру однак
заслугам та вікторії практично всі
противники державного спадкоємство
завищуються проти ти ланцюга твердо фу
коментарі dv і дуже лик укрзалізниці
олександр очерету
російська скроня сотні разил обстрілювала
та stancy та мости кольє вокзали цезар
доєна бату skoda алла ми продовжуємо
avast та апараті та
праведні та вікторія так вже плани та
проти ти на залазите дали стусан не
поважаєш що в ідеях їй до едгару
кожного на любить свою роботу ширвана
лінія
тобто перестати взагалі та ви це я
дещо стануть поїзди, то навіть усі
будемо до кінця Іван так вже прийти і 2 my
city ​​when i buy sweet ремонт але
сказали що гвинт при звучанні і всі люди
не може
на психіку огортав таїться назад за
парижі та порожній вагон на станціях
сторони у нас таке було почуття ван сон
сон був неспокійний поки
вже замарані і всі члени працюючи на
залізничному фронті закінчується людина
готовий пити на реальний залі знаючи сам
наклала броню на пирога тобто нас
допит його warming та всі брали закінчиться
і виробляє топі доварювати
а крин пасажирів вказали злі паровози
тисячі тонн гуманітарного монтажу
також допомагаючи завидним лідером де
статусі до києва та львова
олександр комишина називається заливною
дипломатії та зал м'язи авіаз отримання
геть-чисто вбити а на дорогах чи затори і
вище обидві руки днів обстрілявши вказали
злите стало основним способом з
отримання для всієї України
[музика]